tastebuddy's the first ever taste buds
live stream is upon us May 10th 9 p.m
Eastern Standard time we are coming to
you live from the taste bud no press
Studios with special guests special
surprises and an epic battle that will
be unrivaled
it's 10 bucks it's super cheap you watch
it live and then you have a week to
watch it on video on demand uh and you
can finally vote live you vote live in
real time so check it out and we'll see
you May 10th go to moment dot Co slash
tastebuds we want to see you there folks
Joe DeRosa here I got some live dates a
few dates to throw at you you know how
it goes I Never Promised You a Rose
Garden where and when New York City May
3rd that's this week at the crane
theater that's the last of the residency
run there at least for now uh May 4th
and 5th Pittsburgh that's also this week
doing I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
out there and then into September
because I'm taking the summer off Avenal
New Jersey the Avenal Performing Arts
Center September 16th that's a Saturday
all tickets and showtimes available at
joederrosa.com that's right I got my own
name.com now nothing's got Gonna Stop Me
Joey roses also come through we're open
seven days a week at 11 30 every day say
which is good times and bones Joey roses
nyc.com what's up taste buddies I am on
the road with the Impractical Jokers we
are halfway through the tour adding
dates all the time so check out
impracticaljokerslive.com uh coming up
next May 5th and 6th we are in West
Valley City Utah and Denver Colorado May
19 20 and 21 Arlington Texas The Moody
Center in Austin and Sugarland Texas
June 2nd 3rd and 4th Columbus Ohio
Cleveland Ohio and Detroit at the fox
June 15 16 17 Minneapolis Des Moines and
Kansas City and then rounding out the
last posted dates right now in July
we're coming to Nashville to play the
Grand Ole Opry House uh the Cambridge
Field House in Indianapolis and two at
the stifle theater in St Louis
everything available at
impracticaljokerslive.com
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic I'm talking all right hey folks
welcome to
t-a-s-d-e budge we're here today with a
special guest a very special guest
we have today uh the legendary DJ uh and
and producer Prince Paul with us today
wow thank you for us uh we are major
fans and this is a thrill to have you on
uh we know a lot of our audience is like
who no no a lot of our audiences no it's
in the same exact vein as us so this is
a big deal for us I I've met you a while
back and we've become friends and uh
we're trying to get you on for a while
but to have you here and even even just
to to have a friendship with you is it's
been amazing and I couldn't have said it
any better better Vice Versa oh thank
you very much you know please oh can I
just say that my daughter's here yes you
know all right
come over here for one second say hello
yeah
and she is the reason why I knew of the
Impractical Jokers show okay because I
remember it came what happened like it
was it was on TV and I was like she was
like oh I love this show I'm like I
don't know it looks kind of crazy to me
and then we watched it and from that
point I was hooked oh man so it's so
thanks to her you know uh she opened my
eyes
so much it's always someone always comes
with me and says it tells me the family
member that got them into it which is
it's amazing we um we are we don't know
right now season 10 is airing we just
filmed it and it's airing right now we
don't know if we're getting 11 but if we
do I'd love to have you on
and with my luck there will be no 11.
oh you might know it already and then
have me set up no no no I I truly don't
know but but if we don't get it right
now we'll blame you yeah
thanks no be wonderful to have you I'm
sure we can think of something real cool
to do oh yeah that'd be great see I
think the only problem with that show I
think if I have to do anything like
joking wise as a black band I will get
arrested so that that's that's the only
like bad thing so you have to go
to get somebody else or something like
that you know what I mean like you'll we
won't throw you to the world yeah you
could you could help stir the pot yeah
just as long as you got a good uh
loyalty
all right no problem yeah
it's so it's so cool to have you here we
were talking a little bit before we
started uh but I'm a fan of
stethoson I started with stetsonic and
then in the day law and then into well
Sally right it's the is the one I heard
first Sally the one the one that hooked
me and this was what I was going to tell
you and I wanted to wait till we were on
camera to tell you uh the one that
hooked me I was I think I was in the
sixth grade when speaking of a girl
named Susie
and I might have been in seventh or
eighth grade
thanks yeah yeah but but no when
speaking of a girl named Susie came out
and uh I remember I bought the the Sonic
blood sweat no tears record
because I because I heard that song and
no BS allowed I bought the cassette wow
I used to spend all my money my
allowance money on hip-hop cassettes
that's all I bought and I still have my
collection on my wall and I keep I still
add to it so anyway
um yeah he's the guy when you go to his
apartment it's like the wall of
cassettes yeah wow how many bad ones you
have in there uh I got some bad ones but
it looks good it does look good but it's
mostly it's mostly it's mostly classic
like I remember I went into a record
store and I was on the road in in
Washington state I think and I went into
a hip-hop record shop and the dude he
had cassettes he was showing me and then
I go what are all those and he goes well
these are the ones that are like pricey
because they're more collectible and I
had everyone wow and I was like I I was
like wow I just knew for some reason I
knew not to throw them away when I got
the CDs because a lot of people you go I
got the CDs now I don't need that for
some reason with the cassettes I just
knew like no just keep them anyway
I got the blood sweat no tears record
not as sexy as yours
I love it maybe it's the picture next to
it too that kind of enhances it the uh
the Faith No More picture the yellow and
that pops off of the cassettes without
with our question and then the comic
books behind me we're talking about the
the color and photo composition of the
but anyway oh that's cool so I bought
the this and this used to happen and you
were you'll remember this I bought the
blood sweat no tears record and I I knew
no BS allowed but the song I really
wanted it for was speaking of a girl
named Susie and then the version on the
album was not the video version
and y'all
I don't actually I've never listened to
the cassette so dude I was mad because I
was like it was a different version
where's the version so this is the
reason we brought you here
well let me see clearly yeah yeah so
appreciation cut two uh I still love the
album don't get me wrong I still love
the yeah of course but but cut two
I'm not joking dude like
four years ago I'm in my 40s I mean I
think it was Amoeba Records in LA and
I'm looking at the cassettes and I see
it stetsonic speaking of a girl named
Susie Maxie single unopened
and I like I almost knocked somebody
over because I was like you couldn't you
couldn't get it I remember the
mind-blowing uh remix for Doc's mind
blowing in the video was the remix and
the album version was great but it
wasn't the dream and I found the vinyl
of the remix
like 20 years later 25 years later so
like finding things but you've played
such a big part of my collecting because
the other one of the other things I
bought was the prince among these
records I bought it twice because it
went out of print wow I bought I had
that on double I have two CDs of that
because I knew it went out of print and
I saw a second one I was like I might as
well buy it in case my first one breaks
my mind is blown
sorry I don't mean to be crazy
like I don't be but all right yeah you
know you know what it is is I have a lot
of those things in plastic like in my
somewhere in the basement somewhere and
I'm like huh do you have like a room
full of vinyls I man I have a ton of man
I gave away a lot of vines yeah and just
like with the cassettes we spoke early I
was like oh man I'll give you a ton of
stuff and you're gonna see those CDs and
those cassettes that you bought and
you're like man I could got it for free
or you could sell it no no but never man
cut me in on that all right all right
all right I would I would I would I will
gladly perch anything a huge hip-hop
I'll give it to you like it's it's and
the fact that it would be coming
out of your out of your collection would
be but I'm telling you like the the that
whole that whole Prince among Steve's
record we used to listen to that me and
my friend Pat I had a I had a rap group
for a few years when I was in college
when I was in college you rhymed well I
did I used to give us one run
oh my God
your rap name
he also had a band named salsa windfall
I still do I still do it
know now you heard this feeling yeah oh
he's still existing my rap name was
example which I think is a little corny
not it's actually pretty and I just
could say ex I used to call myself ex
uh I'm trying to we we actually did this
a couple weeks ago I couldn't remember
anything hold on a second oh it's right
there don't try it
a rapper always remembers at least one
run hold on give me a second my name is
Joe and I'm here
all right I think I remember hold on
hold on I was uh it was uh it was uh
half the time okay
I'm gonna try to remember it yeah can
you all do like they do on all the talk
shows and give them a clap no no no no
no dude please don't do that yo please
uh please don't do that
I I I'll go as far with this as I can
remember okay half the time half the
time my motto was half the time my motto
was killed a whole [__] bottle and
stopped making sense like Otto I said it
with Paco gang of foes you a gang of
hoes like a brothel you follow oh wow
wow that was one of my raps
let's examine every line
put up on the screen and can we've got a
bouncing ball
I did not think I'd be doing this today
no but that's cool I mean it's honestly
thank you man respectfully I was really
expecting it to be whack but it wasn't I
wasn't and I said I was too thank you
man it was something
it was cool like I was like wow thank
you and that was way back when that was
that was when I was in college we me and
my friend uh Pat Knowles had a rap group
and we reached out to patent shout out
to Pat no what's the name of the group
Stevie in the example he was MC Stevie
and that was the example why was the MC
Stevie because he wanted to he said to
me one day when we were doing it we we
we were going by different names
and he said to me one day he goes I want
to be MC Stevie and I said what now you
got to remember we were way into cool
Keith that was one of the other reasons
I was so excited about the prince among
Thieves album because that was when
octagon and Doctor Doom I love we loved
all the offbeat of a guard stuff yeah so
we loved the prince among these outside
that was a very avant-garde record in my
opinion especially the turn where you
have ever last played the corrupt white
cop I mean it was just like it just blew
me away anyway
um
he said I want to be empty stupid I said
why and he said because I want to sample
the thing and the deer hunter when
they're playing Russian roulette and
he's got the gunders and they're going
do it Stevie and he goes I want to drop
that in before my verse wow so it goes
do it Steve but his whole name made his
whole name around that and we did shows
for a while we like you know we didn't
like tour anything but we did shows we
had we bought I maxed out
uh oh my I like when I got out of
college they started sending you offers
for credit cards for low limits and I
got some and I maxed them all out and
got equipment and started producing
beats and we we made a bunch of stuff
but it just never and then I got into
stand up and that was it that was the
end of it I stand up start to move so
quickly I just forgot about
about rapping or music did you make
funny rhymes did that lead to the stand
up
me and my okay so me and my friend Jim
pinkstone shouts out to Jim shout out to
Jim we had a group after I started doing
stand-up we did a thing called Deep that
was sex raps and it was all oh yes it
was all exaggerated sex right you know
this that was meant well I know that he
did that I didn't know that no one yeah
we put out one nobody we self released
one album and then I think I heard after
a while
because people didn't get weight he goes
harder I'll give you those cassettes
you're gonna ask me twice but I wasn't
signed by you and who's the other rapper
Jim Jim so my name in deep was Jay Beto
and Jim was uh Jim was um uh uh I keep
looking blanking on his name Jesus
Christ drill Jackson we gave it it was
like porn names kind of you know so well
you got to get and then I do two
characters in deep I do my character and
I do another character named Bernard
Valentine that's a different voice the
people thought it was a different person
for a while wow
I like that name yeah we do that's my
favorite name so far what were some of
your failed names
failed names yeah like what was what
were some of the options you had when I
was like when I was in sixth grade that
was when I first started to rap and my
rap name was uh Cracker Jack
that's mortified
I used to buy the Maxi singles as a kid
and and and I'm sorry it was a little it
was like eighth grade ninth grade
because I remember I bought I had I made
a tape in my uh my bedroom at my mom and
dad's house and I would wrap over the
instrumentals of uh I would buy the Maxi
single so I could wrap over the
insurance so I remember I had I had made
a Cracker Jack tape and the first song
on it was called psycho's path because I
wanted to be a gangster rapper so bad
and it was the scenario remix beat
and I sold that tape in my high school
there's people that have it somewhere
people paid you currency people people
liked it they were like this is good man
and I sold a bunch of them how did you
how did you become Prince Paul yeah
please uh what about the name yeah
because my name was DJ Paul and my group
said it was boring okay so they told you
yeah they was like ah nah man you gotta
change that so they gave me some weird
name it was like kid Maestro and some I
was like uh just just as long as I have
my name in it and people you know and I
went to school with oh that's Paul yeah
did you get ad with everyone to it so it
somehow became Prince Paul it came Grand
wizard Prince Paul and I said please cut
that out it became Prince Paul and
that's that's a Sonic that was the
stetsonic thing okay you're one of the
original guy which is interesting that
story you're one of the original guys
because I never saw a rapper just use
his name regular and I might have there
might have it might have happened Keith
Murray was the first guy where I was
always
but you actually were the first guy one
of the first guys to do that you're like
I'm just going to be DJ Paul and they're
like no no you got to flash it up a
little bit well you know I mean there
was other guys that used their name but
you know uh yeah like I said I had no
choice you know I I mean it was DJ Paul
I think before that
oh here goes a funny name for you my
very first DJ name
was DJ ever ready like the battery okay
wow see I gotta smile like he's like
yeah I got one with you Dad
[Laughter]
oh my God it was its own thing right it
doesn't exist anymore everybody was part
of a door seller no no everybody was its
own it's the silver batteries isn't it
yeah it was Energizer energy
ever ready everybody doesn't exist
anymore I I don't know but that I
haven't seen one of those in a while
yeah see I'm showing my age oh yeah
you're right it had the black cat yeah
remember that remember the the the the
the nine volts yeah that was that was a
classic yo I would like that shirt
that's a good thing by the way do you
remember this do you remember that
everyone was like nine lives the cats
they were like everybody that was like
they held down like they're they
cornered the nine volts yeah yeah they
pulled them yeah they were like door
shells got the Double A's we got the
nine volts no door cell had the D's that
were in the Boombox yeah sure all right
so then who was cornering Double A's
back then
I think it might have been ever ready
energized yeah all right fair enough wow
see so what this really went left what
made you piecing all that together it
says nine lives on the yeah thing wow
that is cool I never really noticed that
that's pretty cool for a battery what
made you uh because you're you're you're
you're
yeah
oh yeah yeah you gotta do it it's so
gross yeah
nothing happens to me though what made
you uh because the thing I I was I was I
actually started to read up a little bit
uh on on some of your like the the the
the
um academic side of your history or
whatever because I knew what I loved
about you and I knew I was a fan but I
was reading up on you and it was I think
Chuck
D might have been the one that said you
he he was like he was the first one that
did that showed people they didn't have
they could sample more than just James
Brown yeah so like what made you explore
that you know I mean I mean that's
that's your claim I mean that's what
everyone looks to you for is that you're
the dj that I mean sampling it was like
right is that yeah it's it's the gift
and the curse you know uh beside the
lawsuits that followed it you know but
um yeah I think just having a wide uh
palette of different music you know
growing up with you know a lot of DJs
especially back then hip-hop guys would
it's whatever Funk Soul records yeah
well you know the radio station back
then played I guess now they call it
Yacht Rock yeah yeah you know and so
they play a little bit everything so
we're all over the place you know what
we listen to and then the stuff that our
families grew up with for example Dave
who had passed away yeah um his family
listened to Country hence three feet
high and Rising sure
see so and that would I mean that was
that the first day out the first one you
did that was like the one that kicked
kicked everything off in that style
right I mean yeah it was it was a lot of
you know we all meshed what we grew up
with I remember I couldn't believe even
as a kid because I was so so raising
hell was my Gateway record that's a
great album so my favorite rap album of
all time is raising hell and that was my
Gateway album to this day to this day uh
it just changed the way I looked at Muse
it changed my life literally I always
say and I have a list somewhere I go
there have been about 30 records in my
lifetime that stopped time
and by that I mean like there were
records that I literally would skip
class till just so I could keep
listening to the rap than that and yeah
so like raising hell was the first and
that that's what brought me into hip-hop
um but that opened the doors to me to to
I like the I always like the harder
stuff I loved iced tea I loved gangster
rap so when I heard Dayla and you guys
sampled Hall and Oates I was like that's
soft even no no
no nothing listen
from the suburbs I was like oh like our
music like white music is also respected
over here because I was like I felt like
we're so like corny like all white music
is so corny compared to the stuff that I
like because it's so edgy so to hear it
sampled and Hall and Oates when you're a
kid I never just saw Hall notes as a
soul group oh but you know what I mean
yeah but they now that I'm older but
everyone gives them their problems yeah
yeah they would sample good music is
good music I mean okay let me ask you
this because you mentioned the 30
records
and I know this happened to me and I'm
sure it happened to you guys you ever
idolize a song or an artist and then
meet them and realize you don't like
them as much in the record kind of Fades
off with that yeah yeah
yeah
I got one recently
yeah we could be but I I was a huge fan
new uh first three albums every word to
every song
concerts everything is a contemporary
artist right now uh these ones are like
Weird Al or somebody we want to be cool
I have no idea but I'm not yeah he's
amazing but then I met him on Nashville
uh at a
pool party or something oh that yeah and
uh and then he was like I no you know
what
this isn't on him it's on me but but he
he was warm as I would have hoped him so
yeah hey let me sign something for you
you know he wasn't even like that uh but
uh I just was I I didn't want to bother
him I think I told the story before so
if I'm repeating it I didn't want to
bother him uh but he was at this party
and he was like very he was dressed to
the nines he was like stood out I don't
know if everyone knew him I knew
immediately but then as the party went
on it was like at this place in
Nashville called like the it was like
the Motor Lodge or something they redid
a whole roadside Motor Lodge into like a
really cool spot and they have this pool
and he's the DJ's playing he's at the
end of it he's up there dancing alone
like really dancing and there's like 30
people left there was 200 people that I
was about to leave and I'm just like I I
had this guy on repeat so I know just
for myself like I don't really like to
approach anybody or whatever I just feel
because I'm also afraid of that and I
just went up to him and I was just like
I just wanted you know like I'm just a
really huge fan and I've seen you in
concert and a couple other things I was
telling him uh but he just kind of just
stared at me and then he kind of just
was like that's what up just when that's
what's up and it kind of turned like and
I was like oh that's not bad that's
what's up is like he said that's what's
up but it was with his middle finger up
yeah he goes this is what's up no he no
he just he just kind of like stared at
me like that and then he just just like
and then he just said it and I was like
all right and then when I walked away
it's never been the same did you ever
yeah I love his music I think he's so
talented did you ever have the opposite
happen though of what we're talking
about I would never meet a guy that you
think his music sucks and then he's so
cool and you go they're pretty good
sounds so much better yeah that happened
to me I swear to God an Avenue with uh I
feel bad I'm not trying to diss the guy
but that everybody would Sugar Ray I bet
Mark McGrath I made fun of Sugar Ray
more than I've arguably made fun of any
band I met Margaret Rath at a radio
station and he was so nice and I was
like you know that's
fly
dude that's funny
the uh but I met I told this I won't
retell the story I met iced tea and
Ice-T was a I absolutely idolized that
oh he's a great guy he was awesome and
he said to me I was at College I was in
college I was about to graduate and I
was about to go out and try to become an
artist and he said to me
he goes then do it go out there and bang
some [__] heads man and I was like
okay it was like that was like the best
case scenario ever I was like I can't
believe I met this guy that I idolized
and he said what I wanted him to say to
me he's a great guy yeah he was nice
Yeah well yeah you know you see you so
you were favoring like crime like the
crime is he your favorite all that
gangster stuff I used to when I was like
it was amazing right but when I was 11
years old tongues is the is the ultimate
when I was 12 years old I used to I used
to ask my mom if we could move to
Compton because I swear to God
you wouldn't be here today man yeah
dude when I heard imagine you walk
around talking about spitting Rhymes
yeah yeah yo that is hilarious I didn't
I just was like please like I was so
obsessed with the West Coast easy does
it like like blew my head off that's a
great album it's amazing what it's
amazing there was this but I couldn't
get enough of that stuff man but I'm
sorry let's try my name
there was this show uh done by um uh who
did uh the white rapper show um the
production company that did the white
rapper
yeah I forget what they're called
they're uh anyway
um that's funny I know because I'm
working with the guy now Sasha Jenkins
who's a part of uh oh man uh right it's
it's at the tip of my tongue man
they have other uh yeah because I was
going to reduce the white rapper show is
what I'm looking for
um it's going to bother me what you come
up to and I'm like that's what it is
you know what's funny this has got talk
about like just the synergy
right here right now you go ego trip yes
great books you go they have great books
I remember saying to you dude you're the
only other guy I know that as the ego
trip top 10 hip hop yeah like like it's
so yeah a lot of hip-hop books yeah so
why anyway sorry go ahead no but they
had this white Rapture and then in one
of the episodes I remember he he took
them all up uh to the Bronx and he went
and he went to like like he went to like
you know you know until I think
um who did they go he and they had him
rap for like all the legendary embassies
and just watching it it was like skin
crawling you know like they did it to
like it was a lesson like oh see where
it came from see where the people who
did it you know give them a little shine
on the show and stuff like that and but
then they were like ah and then they
just started rapping for him I was like
oh man because they weren't really good
rappers either you know like it was it
was a cup it was she was great it was
like two maybe three she's white purges
white yeah
the uh disc there John boys definitely
oh wow Virginia he's from I remember um
Native tongues like it's such a it's
such a wide
oh yeah that was very young oh wait you
were on the show yeah yeah I'm saying
that was just white rapper show I I
forgot that you were on it actually oh
that's hilarious
yes you you literally know specifically
what he yeah this guy was a rapper I've
seen the whole uh you've seen them all
Yeah Yeah from the inside out oh so was
he good 100 Proof was he any good I hate
to say I don't remember
no shade to anyone but uh for me he was
not you for me it wasn't for me Paul
just made a face when he was rapping
like it was okay
on the screen I mean uh
actually what am I even saying this is
this is cringy right now
[Music]
Persia was good uh Sully was had a
little bit hey that's what's her name
that she's a comic is she really yeah
yeah she's a comic she's she's there
[__] around she did comedy raps okay
that was her thing she did comedy wraps
I can't believe that was a long time ago
Jesus I can't believe my daughter
doesn't even know that she's like no oh
man I went out it was so much random
stuff I've done that she has no clue I
watched it when I was out but then me
and my buddy who loved it and watched
the whole thing recently over the
pandemic again were like we found it on
YouTube because they you know what oh
the pandemic when everyone was doing
like specialty Zoom things that never
happened before they had a uh they had a
reunion of the cast and that made me go
back on and watch every episode wow yeah
yeah it was that's cringy for me you
know
do you so wait a minute I literally just
did
the show for you
[Laughter]
and you didn't have to go to the Bronx
people like yo bill was on it yeah and
they were like dig it into them and I'm
sure she was like wait wait you don't
have to go nuts with them they're like I
picked them as contestants wait Ill Bill
was a contestant no no no no
okay there it is yeah yeah yeah that's
so weird to see an empty search with
hair like searches regular hair manager
reached out I recently found out and
said he'd want to come on as well oh I
would love that oh Jokers but it's okay
guys I want to talk to you about C when
you were a kid did someone read
Everybody Poops to you let's just say
many adults have forgotten the details
of pooping anxiety self-controlled
constipation and nervous diarrhea our
conditions many of those experience
throughout their lives but at the end of
the day it's just poop
and seeds ds01 makes it easier to go
seeds ds01 daily symbiotic supports
healthy regularity healthy motility and
ease of the evacuation
it's a symbiotic because it's both a
Prebiotic and a probiotic this is also
there's also increasing research on the
gut brain axis which seed is currently
researching in partnership with axial
Therapeutics
um
you know honestly I don't like to go to
the restroom outside of my home and so
whenever I have to go and I'm not home I
get all the things that they just listed
so this is about gut health and keeping
your regular uh capsule in the capsule
uh safeguards viability through
digestion for delivery of an average of
100 of the probiotic starting dose to
your colon babe the outer capsule also
serves as an elegant barrier to oxygen
moisture and heat so no Refrigeration is
necessary
um let's see what else we got here
what about heart health because it
maintains blood cholesterol levels
already in the normal range and supports
healthy intestinal recycling of
cholesterol and bile gross seed delivers
dso1 daily symbiotic to you monthly and
sustainable packaging with reusable
glass jar that protects the probiotics
inside and helps minimize plastic use
and waste start a new healthy habit
today visit seed.com taste buds and use
code taste buds to redeem 25 off your
first month of seeds dso1 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com taste buds and
use the code taste buds
hello fresh oh I love hellofresh you're
gonna get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
the trips to the grocery store and count
on hellofresh to make home cooking easy
fun and in my opinion most important
affordable that's why it's America's
number one meal kit flavor is in full
bloom at hellofresh enjoy the taste of
spring with Chef crafted recipes
featuring ripe seasonal ingredients
delivered once again right to your door
when the spring Sunshine is calling your
name don't call for takeout stop it get
hello fresh instead the quick and easy
meals make feeding the family a cinch
without the high price tag so you can
spend less time over that stove in that
kitchen and more time out enjoying the
Sunny Rays and the Beautiful breezes of
the Season no worries if you're not a
pro in the kitchen hellofresh's
foolproof recipes arrive pre-portioned
and easy to prepare in just a few few
steps I use hellofresh I enjoy hello
fresh I love hellofresh for all of the
reasons I have already stated and you're
a cook and you love it exactly for
people that are beginning and people
that are experienced because you are a
good what I do like about it is if
you're somebody who actually does cook
and enjoys cooking what you're making is
still an outstanding you're not going
well this is like a beginner thing you
know no this is a solid meal from Soup
To Nuts no pun intended all right okay
anyway go to hellofresh.com tastebuds16
and use that promo code taste buds one
six why you're gonna get 16 free meals
plus free shipping again hellofresh.com
tastebuds16 and use code taste buds one
six for 16 free meals plus free shipping
it's
hellofresh is America's number one meal
kit babe
this I've done so many things that
there's a lot of things I don't remember
it and and I don't smoke which is even
more amazing but yeah it is it's so many
things like the audience has to realize
I'm 56 years old and I started when I
was well professionally when I was 16 I
joined step when I was 16 17. so it's
been a long time wow man well it's like
in the white rapper show I'm looking
like what dude okay dude that's also why
you shouldn't when you were saying
earlier you go oh you're making me feel
old it's like dude you were doing world
tours at like 18. you were a kid you
know like you came out as a kid I'm only
10 years younger than you man you know
like you just you say me I'm 46 as well
yeah but see you know what happens but
you look at a 36 year old like all right
yeah
when I had to do press and I went on uh
Queen Latifah she used to have a show or
whatever the daytime show whatever talk
show yeah yeah it was on I think once or
twice and um I got to meet her and like
like before we started and like she came
over to say hello and everything I was
like I just gotta say
you're sexy
but then I found out she wouldn't have a
crush on me ever
my sister's name is Dana you know
um that was great seeing her at the at
the oh at the at the the day lot things
yeah thank you so much for that by the
way oh no no man any any time but I just
I was like I gotta tell you I've been a
fan of native tongue since the beginning
she's like what and she's like man you
would come up to me and say something
about Native tongues like she wasn't I
think you told me that story and I
didn't and I'm embarrassed that I didn't
know this I didn't know that Queen
Latifah was in Native tongues I was
Associated Queen Latifah with Flavor
Unit oh yeah she was in both but I
didn't know until you said that and I
was like wait a minute no and you were
like no I'm telling you and then that
which was which goes back to what I was
going to say a minute ago native tongues
is such a wide net it's so expand it was
so expensive I didn't know tourism the
beatnuts were in Native tongues yeah
adjacent yeah yeah are they yeah I mean
I mean you got jungle Brothers anybody
who's coming to the studio while any one
of us recorded somehow becomes a part of
it
yeah yeah not as Loose as a war
[Laughter]
so you know but yeah I mean but we all
you know if I borrowed a record from you
came around or I get some advice that we
talked it you know it's part of the
creative process so what was the my
question is is what Native tongues
because it was such a fundamental
uh an instrumental uh uh crew in rap
music and I gotta be honest it might be
the first one I remember like like uh
which it's always I always thought it
was a shame that comedians don't
conglomerize in that way you know what I
mean because they're strengthened which
is kind of like when we made the channel
that our that this show and and the
other show hey babe we're on it was kind
of like that was the mindset was like
let's do what rappers do like let's
think of do a thing together like and
give it a name and whatever so so anyway
my question is is when native tongues
did you guys set out to create this
This Crew uh or was it just kind of like
yeah you know uh well we're doing this
and de los here now
the same type of sounds I mean you were
instrumental yeah I mean I don't want to
do a disservice and say the wrong thing
but as I as I remember it Africa from
the jungle Brothers it all really
started with him right and him bringing
on Q-tip and giving I think he uh Q-tip
is the tribe called um Tribe Called
Quest name and then De La Soul was fans
of jungle brothers and it all kind of
you know it's all like hey we like the
same stuff we listen to the same thing
and it just organically happened I don't
think there was like a meeting at a
table it's like hey native tongue you're
gonna be you know it just kind of
happened did Black Sheep because I
remember the intro on the first place
right everybody that's right Queens
right huh everybody's Queens Black Sheep
two yeah yeah Black Sheep I think so
he lived um he was in the Bronx and I
think he lived down south as well for a
minute yeah he was up in the Bronx
because I told him anytime I went to a
party and anybody wanted to ride home I
told him I lived in the Bronx because
nobody lived in the Bronx so I would
have to anybody to ride home they're
like were you going back home I'm going
to the Bronx I go oh okay that's good I
can't believe that I just can't believe
you man
I
hope it served you well
yeah
oh no it's the greatest era in hip-hop
there are in my opinion there are 10
would I say are Titan producers that I'm
like these guys are the pillars of what
this music is to me at least you're
you're right I mean you're you're one of
them it's wild to be sitting here
talking to you and it's wild for me to
be here you don't understand like I said
my daughter's sitting here look at her
face she's like what my Dad we're giving
you bonus points but he makes great eggs
like she knows me on that level you know
by the way Black Sheep same thing as the
steps of sonic tape I bought it for the
choices oh and that's the mix is not
over
there but it's on the end
version yeah that I heard the video and
then I looked at the thing and I saw the
very last track was called choice is
yours whatever version yeah yeah yeah
and I was like that better be the
freaking video version I was in it was I
was in seventh or eighth grade it must
have been 89 when that that came out wow
I'm old 89. that blew the choice is I
think 90 91. okay yeah yeah yeah eighth
grade I was nine it was 1990. uh that
was like if you went anywhere like that
was the that was the one they turned
like that was the that was the track
that people put on like that turn like
just amped everything like that yeah
yeah that to me the choice is yours to
me scenario was the rap version of
Smells Like Teen Spirit
vice versa it was the energy
it had like the UN as soon as that intro
Baseline comes on same with Teen Spirit
the guitar and it was one of the only
songs where there was a there was a
hip-hop club that they had an underage
night where you could go if you weren't
18 and they do it for high school kids
and they would do it like when you had a
day off from high school they would say
oh we're gonna do underage United I
forget the name of the place that was
the only hip the only time I ever saw
them play anything that wasn't hip-hop
was Smells Like Teen Spirit and all the
hip-hop kids were like head banging too
what I still play because my DJ sets
everybody goes yeah and choice yours was
the same thing yeah Choice yours I
remember seeing Black Sheep the weak Jay
Leno took over The Tonight Show and I
was like I'm seeing a crossover here
with both music and I wasn't seeing that
you were you weren't seeing as that now
it's commonplace but back then it was
like the black sheba's on the tonight
yeah yeah well what was that was it
follow-up was it stroke like honey is
that was that them yeah I think it was
right and they sampled the SOS band and
I don't know yeah take your time right
yeah
had me thinking I'm like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I like that one too that was
that I thought that was a good follow-up
but didn't it's great it didn't hit his
well I mean the other one's iconic put
yeah there's no following that record
it's not it's like it's kind of crazy it
was it was huge man so huge
[Laughter]
uh all right taste buddies we're doing
uh today we're doing octopus versus
oysters
uh Paul our special guest hates both so
he's gonna moderate Sal actually really
likes oysters I really like octopus I
have a feeling that octopus is going to
take the the loss in this one I I folks
let's talk about our sponsor game time
gametime.co have you ever been stressed
about buying tickets all the time yeah
have you ever wanted to go to an event
and then you want to get the tickets to
the event and get the tickets to the
dang event ruins the event well I'm
always trying to hunt down the best
price last minute I don't know if I
should wait I don't know I don't know if
I'm paying too much so you sound
stressing out quite frankly I do when it
comes to people I want to see I stress
point blank
was that a shot at me no no I'm talking
about when I want to go to a talking
about I want to go to a show with you
you're talking okay let's get back on
course here listen here's the thing
people buying tickets should not be
stressful it should not be stressful it
should be easy so you can get to the
event and enjoy the event because that's
what the event is all about and game
time has killer last minute tickets and
the best price guarantee so you can stop
stressing over tickets and start getting
hyped on the fun you'll have right it's
a place for last minute ticket deals
forget planning months in advance like I
do game time is deals on tickets right
up to the day of the event exclusive
Flash Deals on tickets for not just
concerts comedy theater football
basketball baseball the game time
guarantee means you'll always get the
best price and if you find tickets in
the same section or Row for Less they
will credit you 110 of the day and I
like that they also throw an event
cancellation protection that's very very
helpful so anyway
go to gametime.co okay or get the game
time app create an account and use code
taste buds for twenty dollars off your
first purchase terms apply again create
an account and redeem code taste buds
for twenty dollars off download game
time today last minute tickets lowest
price guaranteed snag the tickets
without the stress with game time
you know it's a tough one because
oysters are also polarizing it's a
texture thing and I understand that oh
you're telling me but we were talking
earlier it's like anything with like
that weird type of yeah but can't you
have Oysters like serve different ways
right yeah sure like what are some of
the ways you could have oyster I perform
raw but fried and then I'm sure any
which way a little Rockefeller oysters
yeah which I've had in and I get those
always in Antoine's in New Orleans wait
what is Rockefeller again it's like
cream cheese it's
it's heavy is it yeah they add a bunch
to it it's got
how do you eat it what do you mean how
do you eat it green is money
you guys will know it's got a
Hollandaise sauce that's what it is it's
Hollandaise sauce yeah and I think um
I think uh like yeah I was gonna well I
was gonna say I will say either of these
until much later in life probably well
probably well into my like late 30s or
something like that I wouldn't even look
oysters look disgusting like where you
peer pressure
because the way people shoot them and
they just put a little bit of the like
you know a little bit of the
accoutrement on there you get a little
hot sauce you get a little of the uh
vinegar or whatever it is I avoided uh
oysters for a long time as a kid uh
because I loved Seafood as a kid yeah I
loved We're Not Gonna scream probably in
this one just so you know I I warned him
that sometimes we scream at each other
and we did in the last step but I I
can't see us getting into it heated
battle right now
I mean we can let it rip
yeah we should do the chat don't be well
don't be alarmed by the chant ready yeah
yeah all right here we go it's time it's
time too no no commit to it don't pull
back don't pull back come on ready yeah
it's time two
b-a-t-t-l-e butts all right here we go
you got you got chance yeah we got you
what corresponding thank you thank you
it is amazing yeah it gets a little
embarrassed by this no no no I don't I
don't it always takes a guest Blind Side
I think so I always explain it and then
he thinks I'm explaining it because
whatever I'm explaining it because it'll
hurt why not we just start screaming all
of a sudden
it feels like you're putting baby in the
corner that's all because we can put
baby in a corner
uh
oh oh I loved Seafood as a kid I loved
shrimp cocktail so I loved cold seafood
uh even and I loved cocktail sauce I
loved from a very early age oysters I
held off from not because I thought they
looked gross i j my grandfather showed
it to me and he was like you don't chew
it and I was like I don't understand
eating a food you don't chew that
doesn't make any sense to me well the
not chewing it is the reason I actually
tried it because it looked terrible to
chew but then people like they're fun
you know you get the lemon in that
little cloth you got the Tabasco sauce
that makes you feel like a giant I do
like the lemon in the in the cloth
and [__] like chipped ice it comes out
and all this one's for Maryland this
one's from the you know this
neighborhood and and then you open you
throw it down and then you you get it's
like you're getting all the other tastes
as well like just the oyster in and of
itself might taste a little bit like
salty but I was like oh this ain't bad
but I didn't learn until recently I saw
someone chewing one a raw one I was like
what are you doing like yeah you can
chew them people chew them and I found
out people chew them I chew them yeah so
I chew them but I like mussels and clams
and I will and let me you probably don't
like muscles
this is all a 101 for me like I I knew
none of this all I know it looks like
doodoo in a shell and I was like and I'm
not eating that yeah
Michelle and I'm like yeah you can have
that I will say the one weird thing
about these Crustaceans is and I and I
like all of them right I like all of
them but um and I do like oysters I've
lost my taste for them in recent years
in the last year or so I've kind of lost
my taste for it but I will say the
weirdest why
okay so I lost my taste for oysters in
in more recently than not because there
is the there's a brininess to oysters
okay and often a better oyster some are
more than that though yeah but but often
a better oyster is considered brinier
like if you like nine times out of ten
if you go and I've done this a million
times you go to a happy hour they go we
have dollar oysters you get those
oysters they're flavorless they're good
the brine is really what gives it Flavor
now there's degrees of that what is
Briny Briny it's like a saltwater flavor
a salty flavor but no no that's called
actually Salty's not accurate it's a
salt watery flavor like it is it's it's
everything you don't want to taste when
you look at an oyster yeah I don't like
too much brine myself
I know people that are huge oyster fans
where they're like the brinier the
better I agree I don't like too much but
even the limited amount of it it just
started to get to me after a while and I
oysters are one of those things man you
have a couple bad experiences and I
don't mean bad like they were like
rotten or anything I just mean like you
get that one that goes sideways and
you're like you're like I'm never doing
that again that was unconscious the next
morning yeah your pants are off
how bad does it get well it's supposed
to be an aphrodisiac actually right I
mean they are
if I was gonna say I want to tip my hat
to the oyster oh and I never said what's
weird about the okay what's weird about
the Crustaceans the muscles the the the
clams you're eating the entire thing
it's one of the only Foods where you're
eating the entire Bean you see what I'm
saying less the shell
even a lobster your there's stuff you
don't eat there's stuff you discard
there's stuff you clean out crab same
thing you are op you are eating the
entire organism of a clam when you eat
it period that's just you are right so
it's a lot when you start thinking about
that it's it haunts you a little bit of
a good shuck you know
they shuck it foreign
side that's a like a bar social club
sandwich shop it's very cool exactly the
whole bar top is uh lacquered bar top
and it's all New York hip-hop wow uh
flyers and posters A lot of them from my
bedroom and it's your restaurant yeah
yeah oh see this is where the barter
comes in for those cassettes
come down give me some free like coupons
and stuff give you a couple sandwiches
I'll get you all stewed up with some
whiskey don't worry about it it's on the
arm yeah there's no oysters
no it's like Italian subs it's good man
you come down anytime you guys please
come down but I I love all the Fanfare
that is a raw bar like when I'm at a
restaurant it's a raw bar like a lot of
times it's by the water it's nice it's
just it's always good vibes and it's fun
and you see everything especially when
they have the big displays or when you
get a Seafood Tower comes over and
everything's on ice and a raw bar is
just fun and I think you know voices are
part of that experience so I'm not like
you know the world's biggest oyster fan
but I never thought I would like them
and I really do now octopus
wait I was going to say one more thing
about two oysters I keep saying please
hit my hand thing I want to tip my hats
to the oyster in my opinion
a grand slam date
is you go to like a true Oyster Bar like
Speakeasy Style with the bow ties and
all that stuff and the vests and you sit
down with a lady and you have Oysters
and martinis I mean that is as couge
would say that is class like all the way
that's a great day wow what kind of
dates have you been on
that's like a bad date
[Laughter]
that's still on the mound that's so
descriptive I never like picked up a gal
into a speakeasy had a bunch of oysters
you want to talk about you're getting
loose first of all you're eating an
aphrodisiac second of all you're
drinking martinis it's just yeah no it's
it's old it's classic it's fun man I'm
not saying it's the whole night I take
that that's that's just check for me
yeah all right you know what I mean go
ahead now with the ox well the octopus
uh so yes like I said didn't have any of
these until late in life I was a picky
eater as a kid uh you know you look at
an octopus and immediately everything
inside you says not for me pass right so
especially the goddamn suction cups
right and so never in my life would I
have eaten the noises it took me a long
time to eat calamari as you would say uh
but I even still I don't squid though
okay I only sometimes eat the legs I
usually just eat the Rings because
there's something about those goddamn
suction cups and all the legs and you
know I I was like I know if I could do
this it doesn't help that you know Jason
and the Argonauts fought these goddamn
things out in the sea you know what I
mean yeah like it's like it does it
doesn't have it's literally a sheet
literally like the crack in from like
pirate stories there's a giant octopus
you know if you're a foodie or if you
understand food
to a lot of people and I was always like
oh my God like this is insane all right
the thing about octopuses and I learned
this like it it can be amazing if if
it's in the right hands if the chef is
amazing but bad octopus can be awful
like you know you said you could have a
bad experience so I finally gave it is a
fine you're on a tightrope preparing
octopus
you are
it is it is that's why when you have it
done by a place that knows how to do it
and you get it and they they present
that piece on the plate and there's like
the mango uh like jalapeno salsa or
whatever with it and the you've got the
lime and the cilantro pop and it cuts
tender and it's blackened on the outside
I mean dude it's like nice Char forget
it so here's one doing a Rubik's Cube so
um so I got grossed out of here yeah I
tried it I had a really good rush I
think they'll post or something and I
really loved it and I then I had it for
a while but then I saw like a terrible
video of like
these people taking a knock the live
octopus and like putting it on a grill
and like holding it like it was like
flailing Jesus and that that messes me a
little bit and then I started to read
and apparently wait hold where'd you see
this at it was like a video going around
online
it was in my phone I recorded myself
doing it um
[Laughter]
and then and then I read about it and
apparently octopus are very very
intelligent beings very intelligent they
are and then that weirded me out they
are kind of going the way of the dodo on
menus I believe for that reason like
there there is absolutely I know I know
a restaurateur who was working on a a
his latest thing was going to be a
seafood place and he was saying to me
like he's like we have to really be
delicate if we're going to serve octopus
because they're like there's a cultural
thing now where everybody oh I didn't
know that you know they're really smart
because they did it on like Black Mirror
oh I didn't see that oh yeah there was
this documentary my octopus teacher how
do you know that they're smart though
like who who tested them like how do you
test an octopus well they have they have
their times tables down immediately
yeah you never show up with a picture of
the octopus right yeah
yeah
I mean see
octopuses are extremely intelligent with
a larger brain for their body size than
all animals except birds and mammals
don't they have like eight brains they
are capable of high order cognitive
behaviors including tool use and problem
solving even figuring out how to unscrew
a jar lid and access food like that's
wild to me and then you had another
thing up there uh pimp right before that
that was interesting about them but I
don't know man like that feels that
feels a little I mean look I have to see
that you know we we people eat you know
we eat cows I mean I don't know if they
open jars but you know everything's you
know living but I don't know see okay
here's an octave they have an octopus
solving a puzzle let's see what happens
I mean they these things are aliens by
the way they're they're kind of cute in
their own weird aliens yeah okay
right there's something cute's the wrong
word they're they're they're gentle they
they seem like gentle Giants maybe they
have uh maybe because they have a fluid
yes motion but they are scary and
disgusting they look like they'd be
sweet they look like they'd be oh that
looks like I would run the other way if
that thing was walking down the street
yeah yeah that's crazy right
um
I mean uh you know with oysters oysters
are more I get it that oysters are more
of a party kind of tray kind of thing
meaning like you know you let's all get
oysters for the table it's one of those
things everyone oyster is great you sit
there no one goes Rhonda octopus right I
know well I'm getting to the point you
know yeah I can finish my own uh my
point is is what are they called
suctions but tentacles tentacles but
when you get no but the tentacles you go
to an Italian you go to a nice Italian
restaurant you go to a nice Brazilian
restaurant you go to a nice Spanish
restaurant these they have octopus on
that menu and they make it in a way a
where it's like dude this is like that's
something I would go back to the
restaurant for that sure sure I would go
back I was never into him then I had it
done right and I was like oh it opened
my eyes but then I started to see that
and read up on stuff and then something
just said I don't want to eat this thing
anymore
that's you mean see a comment like this
bothers me octopus resembles a plunger
rubbery suction cups fine and no matter
how you cook it it's overcooked that's
not true it's easy to overcook yeah
tough choice oysters have the
consistency of stock and the only time I
tried octopus I puked
that's what I'm thinking
[Laughter]
now you hate both
yeah tell us why you hate both please uh
I think I mentioned earlier oysters is
like doodoo in a shell yes yeah that's
something I won't eat I don't eat doodoo
right
that's the first octopus
it's just
you know it's something you don't grow
up with in this yeah sure you know your
mom doesn't go hey man Barbecue's
octopus you know we got to picnic
Saturday can you get some octopus some
hot sauce on it so it just didn't look
appealing and I always thought the
suction cups would stick in my mouth but
can you tell me which it doesn't look
appealing neither do can either do can
you tell us what you hate which do you
hate worse gun to your head you got to
eat one of them which which one do you
eat
um I'm visiting the Lord
[Laughter]
since I was a kid I swear to God I never
picked up this as a kid if you said to
me now describe Sanford and Son to a
person has never seen it I go it's a
sitcom about a man that calls his
sister-in-law ugly it plays more of a
plot Point than the junkyard that hit
with the sun I'm like this is the Crux
of the entire show not about LeBron
what what honestly if you had to eat one
I was being very honest
but I can ask you dishonestly so let's
go okay which do you think is more
disgusting or is it a dead dead heat tie
that's it like you can't it's more
disabled in front of you you gotta eat
one for a million bucks
depends on how it's prepared okay am I
eating the oysters raw are they fried
how you would like them you can have
them anyway you can have either thing
Any Way You Want It
I'm a little concerned about the Briny
thing that you explained okay yeah uh
and the octopus as I've seen it open up
that thing of crabs and do taxes
it makes me feel kind of weird about
that but maybe a fried oyster anything
fried could mask yeah usually a fried
oyster too tastes very similar to a
fried clam or it's like are you not with
clams or mussels either
um I
oreganata even what's that oregano I'm
talking to a hood guy you know sure sure
yeah yeah I made a little bit of buddy
but I've you know by Palace yeah I don't
know what that is either what is that
well you haven't heard of oreganata on
anything
what is your reganati oreganata what is
that it's basically a breadcrumb garlic
baked pepper oh that's what that's like
what they put on like baked clams yeah
clams oreganata
don't get you know no but I'm not I'll
come across this couch in two seconds
just put claims are working on it's it's
a big clams but but even shrimp every
everything it's a it's a major that's
I'm actually surprised because that's a
major Staple in Italian cooking they're
called baked clams though in every
Italian menu it says baked clams it
never says clams oreganata
go back to Staten Island I've learned
something today uh it's it's
um
so wait wait what was your question
would he would Paulie clams oreganati
yeah what I eat well because you said
like fried well oreganata really it's
delicious what what is is that a
preparation oreganata is that a
seasoning is it preparation oh okay yeah
what does that entail again it's mostly
breadcrumb I think lemon garlic and it's
just yeah that's it right there it's
just on top
I love shrimps okay it tastes like
shrimp scampi except with breading oh
then it'd be like if you took fried
shrimp and mixed fried shrimp with
shrimp scampi flavor that's kind of what
it tastes like I think that's a pretty
good description right
yeah all right well this is we go to the
phones here because we try to get them
very funny by people's comments we try
to get a Vibe on who's gonna win or lose
before we go to because we put out a
poll at the beginning of this what yeah
so people are voting right now they're
voting yeah oh yeah that's a really
funny quote to eat this is tough it's
like picking between pennies and roofing
nails that's a really funny response I'd
rather have McDonald's for their only
for the rest of my life I love it praise
the world is my oyster [__] said the
octopus is the open jars and
self-complicated math problems
this is like picking [__] or [__] with
uh they called it dude I was right
that's the winner this is like you left
through it this is like picking [__] or
[__] with suction cups on follow Pedro
carvelo at carvelo capital P 30672 but
let's let's ask your daughter too if you
had to pick
you like both of these
so whoa wow V can you pass your mic real
quick oh you don't have any more mice
hold on stop passing your mic real quick
yeah yeah yes we can hear you so you
like both yeah would I rather be shot
if you could you if you had to pick
which you thought was worse of the two
though which would you pick even though
you like both octopus why is that
I I guess it's like
you kind of have to get over it's a
weird looking thing yes okay I just ate
it because somebody was like
in a blah blah blah and I didn't want to
be rude right I was like okay it's not
but it's not something I'm like I'm
gonna go to the restaurant and get
octopus I got you I got you good I like
it do you like fried cow do you like
fried calamari or no because that's too
close calamari that's the explain it to
me it's like a ring oh you know what
happened I'll give you a really quick
story I was in Germany one time with uh
stetsonic okay and we went to this guy's
restaurant I was like oh you know in
this German accent which I can't do will
you come to my restaurant and I sat down
and I was like oh man onion rings and I
grabbed them and I went like this
and it wouldn't break apart and all the
breading and everything came off they're
like what kind of onion ring is it I
don't know it's squid right so you hated
this oh no I was unpleasantly surprised
and I was good after that and I never
wanted it again here is a tip for you if
you ever eat this is a tip forever
octopus has nine brains yeah that's what
I was saying right
squid if you ever order calamari at a
restaurant
send it back
it has to if you do not see tentacles in
different shapes that is not squid it is
pig
hassle that is true that's true that's
really true that's true no no I have a
friend who's a chef it's true I have a
friend as a chef and she said she said
this is a this is a short like they take
Pig [__] and they cut it up because
it tastes almost exactly the same as
calamari you definitely can't tell when
it's fried she goes if you ever go to
like she goes that's why when you go to
like a diner and you get calamari it's
all exactly the same size ring she goes
that is not calamari that is the trick
that is it's a real thing it's real well
that's good to know yeah so you know all
right I I have to imagine you just told
me that at some point in my life I've
eaten cow [__] only 30. and it was
good all-time low of uh votes here 3200
maybe yeah
oh man Jesus all right all right Paul
the way we end this is once we show who
won the winner says to the loser I still
love you the loser says I love you back
but before we do that we want you to
plug whatever you want to plug you know
um
eight de la Soul's album is out for
streaming three feet high and Rising
I'll mention the ones I worked on 359
rise and de la Souls day balloon mind
state if you see it on your streaming
app please uh stream it and I you could
purchase it
um there's also all the other records
I've done the gravediggers etc etc
um
more handsome boy
I wish I could have done the skit on
that man oh yeah next time man please
yeah yeah you said he said he was too
busy and too big for me to try to like
do that are you guys doing a third I
wasn't paying so they had a lot to do
with it are you doing the third handsome
boy
um I I think I think I have retired my
mustache
I'm becoming handsome well an ugly man
that's what happened
you know huge fan of Danny automated Dr
Octagon and then but also too one of my
top five bands of all time is Faith No
More I'm a huge Mike Patton oh and the
fact that you guys had Mike Patton on
the second handsome boy I was like yeah
that that was all Dan you know what I'm
saying because they did lovage together
yeah yeah that's um what about Roselle
you ever work with oh Roselle yeah we
had him on the second handsome boy
record I haven't seen Roselle in a while
yeah you know uh yeah he's super
talented man if you see him before I do
tell them I said what's up
I don't know him you might run two more
that second one I remember I saw it in
the store and I turned a CD and I turned
it over because this is pre-streaming
and I just started seeing all the guest
stars on oh it's crazy and I was so
excited because it was like I'm a big
Lord finesse fan you're the Lord finesse
on it yeah finesse and then you had
dreads on it and drez had not done
anything since the second Black Sheep
album at that point wow well well
anything that I had he had not started
putting out black sheep stuff again
right or yet and I was like whoa he's
got dressed up like it was like you guys
had some major uh features on that thing
man yeah I mean that's that's that's how
we stay handsome yeah you gotta spread
the love and it comes back at you last
thing I just scored a Biz Marky
documentary
um with one of the gentlemen that we
talked about from ego trips Sasha
Jenkins okay that should uh I think it's
going to the festivals this summer oh
that's awesome yeah and uh you know
there's a lot of things but you could
follow me at DJ Prince Paul on whatever
Twitter Instagram and I don't tweet and
I don't post anything
body would you know likes the numbers so
awesome dude thank you for being here
it's great yeah this is too nasty dishes
y'all can give me like one like apple
ice cream well that's when you come back
when you come back we'll do two
delicious dishes all right here's the
big ending this is what we call Humble
Pie when we get the uh the percentages
right now so drum roll pimpy
oh
wow really I am so surprised I'm
surprised octopus takes the win 57.7 to
42.3 wow
buddy I'm coming up on you this season
well you're beating me
this is the first season you're winning
it's still third season he's finally
winning
yeah
all right I still love you bud I love
you too taste buds they coming to the
mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right taste buds man yeah